لاعب جديد يدخل حلبه العداء ويستهدف
الكيان بطائره مجهوله واسبانيا تقف مع
صنعاء وتطيح بتحالف البحر الاحمر واشنطن
تكشف عن الحرب التي ليس لها مثيل خلال
القرن الحالي مدرعات ودبابات الجيش العبري
تبدا مناوره بريه بنشاط استثنائي على طول
الحدود مع مصر والفصائل تعلن عن كميل محكم
للقوات العبريه سلطات القطاع تفقد الاتصال
باسر عبريين لديها تلبيب تبدا المرحله
الثالثه من الحرب والامم المتحده تزف بشرى
سره لليمنيين المانيا ترسل دفعه جديده من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا وسلوفاكيا الغرب فشل
في اوكرانيا وروسيا هي من ستلي
شروطها الفيتو الاوروبي
البحر الاحمر هو ما يؤرق الغرب في الاونه
الاخيره هنا ذكرت صحيفه كونفيدنس ان
اسبانيا استخدمت حق النقد الفيتو في
الاتحاد الاوروبي ضد مشاركه الاتحاد في
عمليه واشنطن لحمايه السفن التجاريه من
هجمات الحوثيين في البحر الاحمر على طريقه
اليمنيين كانت شركه امبري بريطانيه للامن
البحري قد اعلنت ان طائره مسيره اصابت
سفينه تجاريه قباله في رافال الساحل
الغربي للهند مما ادى الى نشوب حريق وهناك
قالت القناه 12 العبريه ان الهجوم على
السفينه المرتبطه بتل ابيب قباله سواحل
الهند تم بطائره مسيره اطلقت من ايران
واليكم المصدر قالت القناه 12 الاسرائيليه
ان المسيره التي استهدفت سفينه مرتبطه
باسرائيل قباله سواحل الهند انطلقت من
ايران مباشره من جهه اخرى نفى مكتب
النتنياهو ان يكون الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن قد اقنعه بعدم مهاجمه مقاومه لبنان
و ذلك على خلفيه تقرير لصحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال مؤكدا انه قرر تحقيق النصر في
الجنوب اولا بحسب ما نقلته صحيفه يدي عوت
احر نوت العبريه في ميدان القطاع اعلن
الناطق باسم الفصائل ابو عبيده عن فقدان
الاتصال بمجموعه مسؤوله عن خمسه من الاسرى
العبريين نتيجه قصف الجيش العبري على
القطاع هذا واعلنت الفصائل عن قتل عدد من
الجنود وتدمير العديد من الاليات العسكريه
العبريه خلال 24 ساعه مع خوض اشتباكات ضار
على مختلف محاور التوغل كما اعلنت الفصائل
تمكنها من ايقاع اربع جيبات قياده عبريه
في كمين وتدميرها وقتل جميع افرادها
وتدمير دبابه هرعت للاسناد وها نحن نشاهد
[موسيقى]
المصدر بينما افادت وكاله ولا الاخباريه
العبريه بان مدرعات ودبابات تابعه للجيش
العبري بدات نشاطا استثنائيا في اطار
مناوره بريه في كرم ابو سالم الى محور
فيلادلفيا الى البحر على طول الحدود بين
القطاع ومصر وافاد الموقع بان العمليه
اسفرت عن سقوط مسلحين اثنين اطلق النار
على القوات العبريه هنا ذكرت صحيفه واشنطن
بوست استنادا الى صور الاقمار الصناعيه ان
مستوى الدمار الذي اصاب القطاع نتيجه
الحرب العبريه ليس له مثيل في اي حرب نشبت
خلال القرن الواح ليصرح المتحدث العسكري
باسم الجيش العبري دانييل غاري بان قوات
الجيش على وشك اكمال العمليات في المناطق
الشماليه من القطاع هذا وافادت القناه ال3
العبريه بانه لاول مره منذ اندلاع الحرب
يستعد الجيش العبري لتسريح عدد كبير يصل
الى الالاف من جنود الاحتياط الذي تم
استدعائهم في القطاع فيما اشارت صحيفتها
ارتز العبريه الى ان الجيش العبري اصبح
بالفعل في خضم الانتشار لاجل المرح الم
حله الثالثه على عكس ما يعلنه صناع القرار
العبريون في حين قالت القناه الح ع
العبريه ان الجيش يستعد لانهاء العمليه
البريه في غضون اسابيع مؤكده ان المرحله
الثالثه تشمل تقليص عدد القوات وتشكيل
منطقه عازله والاستمرار في هجمات مركزه
على ذات السياق قال الجيش العبري ان ضابطا
وجنديا قتلا اضافه الى اصابه 23 جنديا في
معارك القطاع خلال 24 ساعه ومن جانبها
قالت القناه الان ان السلطات العبريه صنفت
3000 من جرح الحرب على انهم اصحاب اعاقات
دائمه في الجيش من جهه اخرى اعتبرت شبكه
ان بي سي نيوز الامريكيه ان تلبيب حققت
تقدما مؤقتا في عمليتها العسكريه بدون ان
تحقق هزيمه استراتيجيه للفصائل وقالت
الشبكه في تقرير ان الكلفه الانسانيه
للحرب جلبت على تلبيب غضبا سياسيا ودوليا
بالعوده الى الحدود اللبنانيه افادت وسائل
اعلام عبريه ان الجيش العبري هاجم عددا من
المواقع في جنوب لبنان وخلال ذلك نقلت
الاذاعه العبريه عن مسؤوله في كيبوتس ماره
بالجليل ان 87 منزلا من اصل
155 لم تعد صالحه للسكن بعد تعرض المنطقه
للقصف وها هو المصدر
يتحدث الى جنوب لبنان حيث افاد مراسل
الجزيره ان مقاتلات اسرائيليه شنت غرات
على منطقه الخردل الواقعه قرب مجرى نهر
الليطاني كما استهدفت ال طائره اسرائيليه
بصاروخين منزلا في بلده كفركلا بينما
اغارت مسيره اسرائيليه على بلده يارون
لننتقل الى اليمن حيث اعلن المبعوث الاممي
الى اليمن هانس جروند برر توصل اطراف
الصراع في اليمن الى الاتفاق على مجموعه
من التدابير تشمل التزامهم بتنفيذ وقف
لاطلاق النار في عموم اليمن والاستعداد
لاستئناف العمليه
السياسيه المانيا ترسل
الدعم دفعات اخرى من الدعم تصل الى
اوكرانيا حيث كانت المانيا قد ارسلت دفعه
جديده من الاسلحه الى كياف واظهرت القائمه
المحدثه للاسلحه المورده الى اوكرانيا على
الموقع الالكتروني للحكومه الالمانيه ان
برلين زودت اوكرانيا باسلحه جديده بينها
انظمه مضاده للطائرات ومركبات مضاده
للالغام في المقابل اكد رئيس وزراء
سلوفاكيا روبرت فيسو ان استراتيجيه تسليح
وتمويل اوكرانيا المغلوطه لارتا اخ روسيا
وحملها على فاوض اثبتت فشلها وان موسكو هي
التي ستمل شروطها للتفاوض حول اوكرانيا
ولنتصور
[موسيقى]
امامكم من جانب اخر صرح رئيس الوزراء
الهنغاري فيكتور اوربان بان تداور
العلاقات بين بودابست واوكرانيا كانت
نتيجه لسياسات كياف وليس القرارات التي
اتخذتها الحكومه الهنغاريه وميدانيا اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسي ان الطيران العملياتي
التكتيكي والمسيرات والقوات الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه التابعه للقوات الروسيه قامت
بدحر القوى العامله والمعدات العسكريه
للقوى الاوكرانيه في 110 مناطق اضافت
الدفاع الروسيه ان جنود وحدات البنادق
الاليه التابعه لجيش الاسلحه المشترك
السادس التابع لقوات مجموعه الغرب الروسيه
سيطروا واحتفظوا على خطوط دفاعيه مفيده في
اتجاه كوبيانسك ومن جهه اخرى اعلن مدير
المركز الصحفي لقوات مجموعه شرق التابعه
للجيش الروسي الكسندر جوردي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه فقدت السيطره على ثمان نقاط
اطلاق نار بعيده المدى على محور جنوب
دونيتس لتعود وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وتعلن
الحصيله بتكب الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من 620
قتيلا وجريحا واسقاط 36 مسيره اطلقتها قوه
كياب على مختلف المحاور خلال 24
ساعه
r